what would you say if you were to rank
your most notable your top
four or top five most notable wins how
would you write mikey
the the fans always congratulate me for
the adrian broner fight
just because i was that was like
so they always congratulate me so that's
probably the biggest fight for me why
didn't he do that
why didn't he act like that you know i
mean that's what people like
you know that's that's one of the most
my feelings just stopped and people
don't want to
shoot him on spot yeah
from anybody
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson i
am your co-host aka
triple c henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
and what a special guest we got here
henry bring him in mikey garcia the
fourth time division boxing world
championships
yeah thank you thank you appreciate it
it's a pleasure to be here man pleasure
to have you here brother
what's going on with your career man
well we uh you know the last guy you
fought wasn't that bone again was it my
my last fight was
a year ago february 29th 2020
that was that was the previous year um i
had a fight after the fight with arrow i
fought
jesse vargas um february 29th of 2020
right before the whole
covid pandemic yes you know hit
everybody so
um now i'm trying to get back i'm trying
to get back in in the ring trying to see
if we can schedule something
uh for for this summer who would you
like to fight i mean the name keeps you
know
coming up you know and we would love to
fight manny pacquiao 47.
i think i think that would be a great
match up uh styles wise i mean he would
like to fight him at 47. you wouldn't
like him at 140.
he's been fighting he's been fighting
out 47 so i'll come down
you know but if if if he's willing to
come down a little bit then i'll yeah
yeah because you're you're a natural
40-pounder i mean if you have to say
mikey garcia i am a natural 140-pounder
i think god that's right i'm i'm
naturally he's a smaller fighter
you know so 140 fits me better
but because manny's been fighting on 47
you know that's why i would i would
campaign at 47.
but um fema came up to 140. would you
fight oh yeah
that'd be a great matchup i'm thinking
about thought about that fight yeah you
thought about it
and he meant he himself said that he
might be moving up to 40 soon
uh we were just talking about before we
went on that english guy
think he could probably handle that
english guy um you're talking about uh
josh taylor you're talking about josh
yeah we're talking taylor right now
so i mean taylor and ramirez have a
fight
saturday night you know and ramirez is
my boy you know i wish him
you know the very best depending on how
that outcome of that fight you know
maybe i can jump in there and
get get some of those those titles that
are going to be there man
it's exciting right now with what's
going on in box especially you guys
weight class i know you come from
millennials your family that have been
boxers obviously
your dad is is infamous for training
some of the best fighters in the world
yeah your brother
sure uh fernanda vargas i mean the list
goes on margarito
yeah i mean who else could you uh oh man
you know we do come from a big boxing
family there's a lot of fighters huh my
my brother
when my brother robert was boxing he was
champion he fought on some of your cards
yeah my brother robert he found some of
the cards he was he was the
co-main for for some of your events damn
that's when i
first actually met met mike uh i was
like oppressor out on the mgm
i forget exactly who you fought then i i
don't know if it was
francis or or or
norris one of those fights and i met you
there i was a kid i was like 10 years
old
my brother was the co-future on that
night and that's the only time that i i
had met him
um
but i i clearly remember you know mike
tyson you know
so i was a little kid that's all i did
hung around fighters
that's all i did nobody if you were
something else because you were in the
boxing gym that's how i met you
yep yeah that was my whole life yeah and
i was just lucky that i was you know
there because my brother like said he
was fighting so
yeah how was it growing up man because
obviously i've seen a lot of you guys as
24 7
sure you know with your family i mean
it's gone to the point even you know
without the respect that even
the box you know boxing the relationship
has even kind of torn
sometimes with with your brothers i
don't i don't know how the situation is
now
no um look we've grown up in boxing our
whole life um
my dad started you know with his you
know
son robert and and danny you know my
brothers you know when they were kids
i grew up watching them you know at the
gym training and whatnot
eventually they've become trainers
themselves robert and danny have become
trainers
um and yeah sure there was there was
some some conflict some some friction
between the family sometimes
over fighters you know and they kind of
separated
uh you know the family uh for a bit now
it's all good
we're all good yeah it's good um so
that's that's always good to to have you
know the family
united again um and there's no there are
no problems there's no beef
among anybody but you know that's in in
any big family
you know things happen especially
mexican descent mike
and then i think passion with any family
is pretty
you know i mean sometimes right right
man a four-division world champion like
that's that's that's crazy man
126 130 135 140.
yeah now you got one more i'm trying to
secure a fifth division
who's the biggest champion 140 pounds so
it's ramirez and taylor winner takes all
four belts
yeah you know the winner takes all four
balls and you can make that division
popular
oh yeah no and there's like you
mentioned right now maybe tofimo lopez
jumps up to 140.
some of the guys that are 135 can easily
move up to 140 soon
which would make for for a much
difference
those guys that'd be awesome would you
like to be willing to come back
sometimes
there's a lot of time those are the big
money fight
there's a big fight with him though i
remember like a few a couple years back
with you versus la maschenko
yeah lamashenko was on you bro i was
unified champion at 135
he was also a champion at 135. you know
what really kept that from from actually
happening
is just my old relationship with top
rank
kind of keeps that from from getting
those fights
being that lomachenko was the top ranked
fight is a top-ranked fighter yeah
that's always going to be an issue there
and
and in order to get those fights top
rank it's
a little harder to work with me it's a
little trick that's the politics you
know the pop-tart
box and box out yeah it's not so much
like the ufc
it's like it's like a catch-22 it's a
double-edged sword it's like in the ufc
we're under one umbrella and boxing
you're going up against different
promoters different networks
now you got the pbc showtime hbo is no
longer there yep
they've been cut out but it's like dude
in some way
you guys make a lot more money but
sometimes we don't know i mean
when are we going to see more of the
biggest you would want to see the the
best fighting the best right
we as fans because i'm a fan you know
not just i'm a boxer but i'm a fan of
the sport
and we would love to see more of the the
champions facing each other and the
the biggest fights you know coming
coming along
but like you just mentioned you know and
mike knows it very well when you got
you know different promoters different
managers different
networks working it just complicates
things
how long did it take for for you guys to
do the tyson lewis
you know because of showtime hbo bunch
bunch of
bunch of things that that were there do
you remember that mike do you remember
hold on forever
i mean i remember the fighters didn't
want the fight it wasn't gonna happen
you know the fighter guy keep pushing
for the fight yeah because see you got
different promoters fire guys say if i
don't fight him i'm not fighting nobody
that's the only way he's gonna get it
done yeah yeah so
it's very complicated to get some of the
fights even though we would love to
i would love to take on all these fights
yeah you know sometimes
the politics you know get get interested
with that the policy but sometimes
is is it about the money or is it more
about i mean what is it about do you
think typically
what ends up happening from my
experience is that
a promoter gets a little
greedy and isn't willing to share
all the revenue that's there to get the
fight to go down you know
i think this is why mike always says you
need two things yes you need
your training you need your lawyer you
don't need that number so they know
entourage
and that that's why that's why i do it
all myself now i do i manage myself i
promote myself
you know i work on you know with
different people but that's why legends
only league
you know no easy fights it's just it
fights without a promoter you do your
own thing we don't own you you don't own
us and
you want to fight with us next time good
yeah that's what it's all about
yeah it's it's i think what makes mikey
garcia extremely special
is the fact that you started boxing at
the age of 14.
yeah and that's your freaking super
technical dude
thanks you know what i'm saying like i
watch a sport i'm a fan just like you
guys i love boxing you're
a super technical fighter because i i
will be honest with you
i was doubting you i didn't think you
could have taken out adrien ball like
you did
or even believe in vargas but you know
but you taught me something
yeah skills dude footwork angles this
just timing being raised in the sport
you know
main experience too that helps a lot
experience is the best teacher
yep yeah fighting that is yeah i mean
like i said
just growing up in the sport you know
it's
i seen it with my brother with robert i
seen it with fernando
you know with vargas so as i'm growing
even though i started a little later at
14
but i've seen something i grew up in it
so that experience is still there
and as i start you know fighting
professional whatever because obviously
you know we
gain experience everything you think
about at the age of 14 starting boxing
then you're now you're a four division
world champ
yeah that's pretty extraordinary this
doesn't happen over the night no it
doesn't
you're right it doesn't definitely
happen you go through a lot of defeats a
lot of robberies they rob some decisions
you go through crying somebody
throwing a trophy on the floor you go
through all that stuff yeah but it's
almost like this too mike because i
think of your career and your story you
had costumato when you first started
he had his he had a uh his hall of fame
father and his brother
you know what i'm saying and he's you've
been able to grow up amongst some of the
best boxers you've seen
the good the bad at the other yeah
that's that's um that's an advantage we
have yeah yeah
we know what could possibly happen we
saw our brothers we saw people close to
us
make a lot of money and throw it away we
saw people almost made it was the best
fighter in the world
then got arrested and killed you already
saw we saw those trap holes exactly
damn
why is boxy so brutal like that man like
a boxing box is just a different
difference you either watch it or you're
this is
it because um the lowest of lowest
you know i'm not saying this character
but just the
the bottom of the barrel fight who who's
gonna fight you know what i mean
who's gonna do that career really it's
like if you can go to school you think
you gotta go get punched in the face
you know mike has a brother who's a
brain surgeon yeah wow
that's just fresh stuff you know that
imagine if you could go to school
be an actress and you wouldn't have to
worry about getting punched in the face
but
it's really strange person that really
does this he's looking for some kind of
respect some kind of glory
in some way he may not say but he's
looking for that somewhere
he's seen the guy that he thought that
was like that and they wanted to be like
that
i saw the guys with their shirts off and
their muscles and their belts oh man
yeah i want to be like that
yeah i'll be just like those guys get
the belts off
look at your confidence i wish you dare
come near me yes
i started talking that blew my mind
roberta's around and she
was literally blew my mind how old are
you mike
i fought to you and you started boxing
at what age 14.
oh wow yeah that's crazy but when i
watch those guys
right that's what i want to be yeah
damn those are you guys who who inspired
you mikey because i
imagine being in your shoes max i have a
little nephew and obviously my brother
was a successful wrestler
you know i went out to be you know
become an olympic champion ufc and all
that
and i feel the pressure on him as an 11
year old kid man
yeah we don't let him compete or wrestle
for the fact that man this [ __ ] is hard
it is tough you know what i'm saying i
feel for you bro look my
my dad didn't want me to box he didn't
he didn't really want to box
he had his you know he had my brother
robert and danny boxing
and obviously they knew how tough the
sport really is so they my dad didn't
ever push me to box he actually kept
telling me to maybe go to school
do something else you know but uh when i
was 14 i told him you know i want to
give boxing a try just
so you're a freshman yeah freshman high
school just
just freshman high school that's late
for boxing
but that was you too much yeah i mean it
was late i had my first my first amateur
boxing match at 14 just hey let me try
it out you know
yeah then as as things developed as an
amateur and i
made it to national uh tournaments and
then i won a few nationals
i saw an opportunity to listen to it you
don't forget this
now you go to the tournament everybody
know your name yeah
now we get to inspire the young kids you
know i go to a few a few shows amateur
shows tournaments and whatnot
and the kids look up to me and
everything so that's that's that's
really
nice that we get to inspire the young
kids you know
to to do great a lot of times kids will
tell me i want to be like you i want to
be like you
and i always tell them no no no no you
got to be better you got to oh man
listen i met alexis i was like 15 now
i thought i was going to die really so
just uh yeah
i saw people see you now michael yeah
killer
oh one punk argo versus pryor those are
all great great fights dude those were
four those were 15 round fights right
back in there
man you guys kind of both are
unbelievable fighters man
you know man they're crazy fighters ways
to hate guys buff the
them go to the bathroom on themselves
yeah oh he's
vicious and mean so our loyal was
he was right before duran and and and
the west
and he was releasing the same thing he
came pro in the
1960 late 60s 67 68.
yeah so what was arguable what weight
class was where was a hundred and
thirty 125 pounder 135
140 and yeah it was four four twenty six
and thirty were like his best best
division yeah yeah thirty five
thirty two five he was the champion then
he went to four thirty five hundred fish
he was the older guy it's made up
beautiful beautiful right hand
yeah oh god breaking some iphones
yeah because you know we're probably
about the same i'm 34 how old are you 33
yeah yeah you're i'm 87 you're 88 87 are
you 80 17 you'll be 34 though
this year and he was from nicaragua and
they didn't have all that steroid stuff
and all that stuff like that
he stopped getting normal better and
better as he got older
yeah he knows the other generation bro
you know what i'm saying yeah
these other guys are killers born
who were who were some of the guys that
you looked to growing up in boxing
and particularly you know obviously come
from mexican descent um were there
people that uh
well so so when i when i was starting to
box like i said my brother was still
there
fernando vargas was still there so
obviously i see them at the gym so that
was always there
but people that i admire outside were
fighters like juan manuel marquez uh
martino barrera
and eric morales you know i grew up
killing
generation where i was the kid that was
you know admiring them you know
so that was that was true
grandfather is mexican he fought yeah
he's the ram a burden around father is
mexican
he he fought just like like like mexican
yeah right
right yeah but then again to you a
little bit
earlier you didn't remember salvador
sanchez i i i've seen video off yeah he
i've seen the videos i've seen his
fights uh against gomez
oh someone nelson nelson and those are
great matches
have you ever seen them you know what i
mean gomez was a monster
though yeah that was
that was a great match a great fight and
then there's someone else in fight too
whoa and that was the greatest there was
another fight named loopy pinto from
star you know them all bro they were the
greatest right
it was great he's a boxycon
yeah yeah ripping the body shots and
left most stop nonsense
he was like a native american and uh
never never never ever got tough
do you remember the fight with uh with
oscar and uh
and chavez back i do yeah i remember uh
yeah because you're young i was like so
washed up then
he went into the fight with the gas he
had a gas and said he went into the
fight
my my dad my brother my oldest brother
danny i remember them talking about it
and i remember watching it
they actually went to like a place that
was showing it
like closed circuit yeah because they
weren't showing it for a certain area
you know so the fire whatever
yeah like closed circuit so they
actually went to a place to watch it
um and i mean they came back you know
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know like
they're so different than
someone i was so mad at asking for a
long time no no i think i think people
i didn't like them for long people
didn't like them for that reason people
didn't like them for that reason because
we
yeah yeah no but yeah i mean chavez who
i mean
what could you say you know he didn't
didn't touch the canvas until like 90th
fight or something [ __ ] you know
never did never got cut i never got you
know swallowed like
yeah one of the greatest
when he fought when he fought the the
fights that
are like the most memorable like but
listen you know
who has a record he has legendary record
over 100 fights
who else you want to see now listen i'm
not going to live to see another fighter
without
no one else who's 100 he had 105 fights
right something like that
what was it 115. what was like 89.90
knockout something like that
yeah yeah that's he had to draw against
a rand
yeah uh whitaker was it wrong with water
and then he beat him the second time
beat him the second time
that's what i'm saying but like these
dudes like even the the what made chad
was extremely special is that
he was technical but he didn't have that
finesse like like let's say a black
fighter
no but he was going out there listen you
never see him get hit he didn't get hit
yeah defense on the inside great defense
it wasn't fancy defense because you
didn't get hit much of the smart box
it was on the inside a lot of head
movement did you guys feed off of each
other mike you guys were the same era
yeah i hung out with him all the time i
looked up to him like my hero back then
yeah
i used to go to cool economy used to
hang out
in there boy beautiful
[Applause]
your name is numbers now
julio
what's that lee do it translate for him
hey champ how you doing champ you look
beautiful look like a young boy
i want you to be the referee for his
fight who would be fighting camacho kid
yeah i would love to yes yes i would
love to wear the fight at
least
there we go we got legends everywhere
mike's about to be your wrath
right then the calendar june 19th that's
cool man looking forward to it now mikey
with uh obviously man you've gone up
against
uh of the best at 147 yeah that's what
the [ __ ] you doing fighting that was
spin bro
saying
it was it was a weight issue it was uh
yeah the
size the size i could tell that but god
leave mikey you didn't show composure i
know you heard even your dad and your
uncle
had thought about even pulling you out
closer to like the later it was like in
the eighth round when my dad and my
brother were you know pretty concerned
yeah rightfully so and that's they're
not supposed to you're doing they're not
they're
they're they're you know protecting
they're trying to you know protect what
happened
not her but they just seen a lot a lot
of you know
you didn't look nice no i didn't i was
never really hurt honestly i never got
stunned
never got hurt it was a boxing match
they saw that arrow was
coming on stronger and stronger and
maybe trying to stop me
trying to look for the stoppage so they
asked me in the corner say hey how do
you feel because
you know we don't want you getting hurt
we don't want you getting punishment and
it looks worse than it really was it
looked worse than it was i told him i'm
fine
i'm not hurt he never hurt me um i'll do
better this next up coming around so you
can see
so they saw me the next few rounds and i
was doing better and they
let me continue my fight you know but
yeah i mean at the time no one wanted to
get in the ring with arrow
when you trust [ __ ] he fought that
[ __ ] do you want to do no
running or nothing yeah we were there
and and i would do it again i i would i
would jump in there again
i've been i've been feeling better yeah
because i've been carrying the weight
more
yeah uh better now so i think i would do
better we made some i had no idea
that's good that blew my mind yeah i
mean that night then it made me remember
sizing [ __ ]
no look at that [ __ ] the the
size that you know advantage that he has
you know he he is taller and a bigger
man naturally
but i can use defense i can use speed
i can do other things unfortunately that
night i was not able to
really put it together i i made some
mistakes probably
now looking back i probably made some
mistakes i rehydrated a little too much
on fighting that i was a little too
heavy slow i got tired i felt sluggish
you know so i wouldn't do that again
when i fought jesse vargas this last
year i didn't do that i i thought i had
a more comfortable weight
listen to your where i could be you know
to your body yeah just
comfortable speed quickness and that's
what i did
i fall out better he's a tough loving
tough guy tough guy
he's a big dude he's tough but we fought
him a little differently you know i
like i said i listened to my body you
know i found more comfortable i didn't
rehydrate too much you know when i
fought arrow we did
you know uh we thought you know we
should gain more weight so we don't have
so much such a huge disadvantage
yeah but i mean he fought great he
fought a great fight he's a terrific
fighter
he has great timing great footwork you
know he can manage
the distance and everything i mean he's
goliath now so anybody wants to see
somebody give him a good fight
so when you go live it's hard for people
people want to see you
push you push i would i would love to
get you know
one or two good wins and and try to
challenge him again
how do you how do you see and how do you
obviously now that you've been with her
you've been there with earl spence
how do you see him matching up with the
terence crawford with the
pound-for-pound king right now
yeah i'm sorry i thought you thought
clock off the crosstalk first
i mean i think crawford's more dangerous
i think i think the weight
the weight difference wouldn't be much
robert has moved up in weight also from
lightweight
so physically uh speaking that's what i
mean that's a better
matchup because he's also moved up in
weight versus how
errol spencer has always been on but but
crawford's got more skills but the
skills are different
righty southpaw yeah switches what i'm
saying
powering his right pawn that's a toss-up
fight for me i think that's
you know between that i think i like
that one better than ever i would love
to see that one
yeah i was on the phone with you you
mentioned that yeah if we were to talk
about about me
i want to see crawford push towards him
pushed you want to see him push
he hasn't fought anybody like that has
pushed him lately you don't think so
i i think i remember he beat that uh
that horn from
you know the one that beat pacquiao he
beat benavidez
i think people are ducking him dude i
think he's that tall guy
yeah the guy that's not yeah i'm talking
about the guy that's the middleweight
guy
that's his brother's brother that's it
that's his brother yeah
look with crawford you run into the
issues of the promotion again
gamboa and and that's the reason why
he's unable to get
securing those other fights that we
would all want to see him fight
we would all want to see him fight like
you mentioned arrow spans they were
talking about him and keith thurman
prior and
uh they were talking about him and danny
garcia and sean porter
but you're unable to do that because of
the politics i love business i love to
see him and danny garcia go for it too
yeah i'd be
yeah danny just got he just got beat up
by aerospace harold spence yeah
i mean something something something the
147 pound it's been known to be
just like back in your day mike you guys
are heavyweights
man like it has i feel like that's like
the probably the most special week class
one of the most premier
weight classes always has been
highlighted with great fighters
go back in time you know you had the
shoe ray leonard the
whitaker the oscar de la hoya felix
trinity i all started that lightweight
division is a [ __ ] too boy
yeah at the beginning of the time the
light which has been a [ __ ]
yeah in the light weights and
heavyweight that's how it first started
out those three divisions
in the lightweights you've always had
like you know you had duran
you had chavez you know um
he's just the best of you you always say
lightweight's the best division yeah
what would you say if you were to rank
your most notable your top four or top
five most notable wins how would you
rank mikey
my most uh memorable wins notable wins
notable memorable whatever that could be
in categories um
the fans always congratulate me for the
adrian broner fight
just because i was that was a big fight
nobody liked bro
that's why so they always congratulate
me so that's probably the biggest fight
for me
why didn't he do that why didn't he act
like that you know i mean that's what
people like
why does he act like that but he's
actually pretty chill
he's actually pretty cool when when
we're actually hanging out a couple
times that we've we've run into each
other
he's a different person well he needs to
number two would be uh my first world
title fight against orlando salido
um
before and then so that was that's a big
fight for me you know
winning that fight yeah you are you beat
him off 12 rounds bro i was i was tough
i dropped that four times yeah you know
i just
boxed real well um third would probably
be
uh my win over de jean slatikanen when i
won
my lightweight wbc title
from montenegro montenegro yeah where's
that at european
european you wrote that fight yeah
that's 2017.
that was my my third division where a
lot of people
didn't believe i had enough because i
was coming off of a two and a half year
layoff
so they didn't think i was ready to take
on a yeah on a champion like himself he
was being avoided also at the time
and and so that's that's very memorable
for that reason and notable
my fight over over robert easter
unification
against robert easter unification oh
[ __ ] that was that was a great fight
there staples center yeah
big big fight big fighters on the field
you saw that you saw that
you saw that fight no robert easter
there was a good good fight for me
both undefeated champions at the time
all right that's four you got one more
man
one more after that no you can't have
one better than that
you said the best well not yours that
would be number one then i'll tell you
what i got number five for you and i
think it hasn't happened yet against
manny pacquiao
ah i love that what are we what matt
what better yet
what what is gonna take for you to fight
manny pacquiao
you guys gotta put up a lot of money for
for manny's oh yeah that's all they do
to put up money
hey but mike said it the best it's the
fighters that asked for it right oh he
he look i spoken to him man if he wants
it
he wants it he's he's mentioned my name
is being determined he's hot right now
he is he's excited he's always
mentioning that he would love to
do a fight with me i love him i love to
see you fight him in lightweight too
i i would actually like him at a lighter
weight i think he'd love to see you
a better fight yeah he would be super
fast at 140. the only reason that
we were talking about staying at 47
because he was holding the wba battle at
47. yeah
that's when we took from keith thurman
right from keith thurman and recently
the wba had kind of
removed him because they had oogas kind
of in state as a regular champion
but i'm sure once manny's back they're
going to reinstate him see he never lost
it he's just been active
you know because of inactivity he's one
of the money guys so
that's the reason for for the fight to
be at 47. but i think if we were to
fight 140
you know it wouldn't change much you
know the fight
i don't mind you know 140 147 yeah kids
family men how many uh
you got a three kids you got three kids
man my oldest my daughter she just
turned 14.
oh no you had yours so
you're 20 i was 19 19 19 19
my daughter then i have two boys my
older boy he'll be 10
next month and my little my little one
he he's six
so 14 10 and six oh wow they're all yeah
they're all different different age
groups yeah
that's awesome yeah um the little one
shows more interest in boxing
he's he's constantly punching the bag
and hitting the mids and
the little ones always just trying to
punch something he'll be here and he'll
start punching the
the cushions or you know he's always
punching me he seems to be the one i
have a lot of energy to burn to do this
stuff
oh man so maybe he decides to do some
boxing later i don't know
yeah i wouldn't push him either i
wouldn't be pushing him to box
but if he wants to do it i'm gonna
definitely support him especially if i
see that he has what it
is absolutely i'm gonna put i'm gonna
support him that's cool 100
what's what's what's next on the horizon
man for the garcia family man for your
brothers i know
uh there's one guy that i'm super
impressed with today you guys are
actually the same weight class
that virgil kid virgil does your brother
train him yeah
have you seen him fight ortiz virgil oh
my god he's a killer [ __ ] he's mine
bro mike let's hear it let's hear one of
those like whoa
check it out put some put some
highlights somewhere there virgil ortiz
yo mike this dude here we go first jesus
dude
you put some highlights you can do some
highlights on the right or left
this verge over here yeah on the left
yeah yeah this dude's already he's like
he's
looks are deceiving bro he's out of his
[ __ ] mind look at him
he's been winning oh [ __ ]
did you hear that mike 17 knockouts look
at that skinny it's like tommy harry is
[ __ ] killed yeah
oh man but how old is he he's he's young
dude he's like
20 yeah just turn 21 [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
his last fight was uh i think in april
he uh he beat uh maurice hooker
yeah he's [ __ ] man this this kid is like
ridiculous man
he's he's not you got to see us he won
135 47 47 man he's already called out uh
here he called doc crawford i mean the
kid is right let him fight that guy
boots and his boots and his boots that
would be a great matchup too
oh baby beautiful body look at him look
super tempting these
we always work with each other and
that's that's what makes our gym you
know
very successful too very good because we
work with each other
you know they keep saying oh iron
sharpens iron you know we
we work with each other we train we give
each other tips
uh but the best work obviously in
sparring you know that's where you
you really get to work man i would love
to be there just for a whole week just
to watch you guys you know what i'm
doing
come down anytime you want monday
wednesdays or not too far just to watch
[Laughter]
just to just to watch uh you know monday
wednesday friday sparring sessions
starts at noon
it's a full house man tons and tons of
sparring you guys are in oxnard right
now we're out here in riverside oh
riverside so yeah we're in riverside
yeah no and anyhow mike he's uh he's
he's a vicious uh
he's he's super vicious we have a lot of
fighters at our gym um
virgil you know being one of the top
prospects we have other fighters there
too uh
um josh franco world champion his
brother
jesse bam rodriguez you know and these
are all undefeated kids coming up and
coming you know
from our gym yeah they're they're just
you know terrific
oh body shop i'm telling you mike this
kid is he's 21 years old yeah
well wait what wealthy huh well 147.
he's already ranked i think number one
by the wbo i think
number two number one by the wo there's
nothing man like having like that that
mexicans
like you know what i'm saying it's like
that combination of being a savage and
being a technical
yeah that's not smart you guys would
never fight you guys you guys would
never fight each other no
we're in the same you know team of
course so we wouldn't fight each other
there's
that's why there's four different belts
yeah you know that's what's so good
about all these championships so much
for everybody
now we got more championship fights at
one time when i was champion out uh
featherweight my brother had me wbo
champion at featherweight
he had jesus cuellar wba champion at
featherweight
and evgeny grodovich the ibf
featherweight champion
all three titles he ever went trainer of
the year he he didn't get trendy leader
that year
oh that's true and that year he won a
second title with me
when i fought rocky martinez yeah i met
with him
he dropped me i remember yeah rocky
martin is he's in the tough fight
yeah and then he also beat uh broner
with marcos madonna for the title
yeah so that year my brother won
five world titles that year and he still
didn't get trend of the year
politics yeah yeah absolutely
like i said master what's next for the
garcia family well i guess
and what's next for you so my brother
keeps very busy like we just mentioned
you know ortiz we
tanahara all the other guys there you
know lindorfo delgado
so he stays real busy you know as far as
long goes for me
i'm trying to get something for the
summer like i said maybe late july
early august if if the fight with manny
doesn't happen because we've been going
back and forth but it
just hasn't hasn't come to fruition then
then i'm gonna look to see who
else is available i'm gonna see who what
other options whether it's a 140
or 147 you know profit go fight crawford
man chris carter needs an opponent and
then i'll step up
graphic you know yeah so yeah we that
the 140
they definitely need that man if you
were to leave your legacy
mikey how is it that you want to leave
your legacy man i want people to
remember me for
for not you know not babysitting a title
not
you know ducking guys not going dif
around i won't
be remembered for for the guy that fired
everybody
when everybody was still at the prime
you know not catching people on the way
out and not
trying to take loads of everybody
nobody fight everybody and and and took
on the biggest challenges they don't
even let you fight everybody even if you
want to they don't even let you fight
the great guys
that's crazy right that's that's all the
politics and business that that keep
those
from happening you know but with me i
just want to fight everybody that's
that's available
biggest five biggest challenge that's
how i want to be remembered
as a legend mike what advice would you
give mikey in his career
no listen um mikey's the legend now you
know i mean
mikey knows what everything he's been
doing has been perfect you know i mean
and he's even an overachiever i never
knew that he could fight that welding
against those big opponents thank you
thank you
i mean i'm very impressed with the um uh
fight
thank you that really uh impressed me
and for for someone that that
like myself that started at
featherweight you know people wouldn't
imagine that i'd be fighting you know
at welterweight ever and i'm i'm still
holding my own there you know so
i i yeah i thought that after that was a
little crazy though to be honest
with you but you did it you came out
everybody everybody you know it's it's
gutsy
yeah that's exciting it's in the heart
you know it's it's yeah no brains are
involved
yeah you have to man no brains are
involved
i remember wishing you luck for that
fight i remember saying that you sent me
a message
i was like man i said he's gutsy because
i went up a weight class yeah and i was
the underdog
yeah i ended up knocking that dude out
you know what i'm saying i remember that
so it's like you know i was rooting for
it because thanks
man that's that's another weight class
that's the there hasn't been too many
no no no that's not another weight class
with the most vicious guy in that way
god crashed come
what it is on that's what it is
that's what it is thank you thank you
yeah i mean we
i'm actually i'm down we're down to
fight anybody you know biggest five
biggest challenge
you know the fights that people say i
shouldn't be taking that's that's what
i'm gonna be taking just to show
everybody
that i can that's what's so that's
that's really what i want to be
remembered for
awesome man well man it's it's been a
blast for me it's been a blast for i
know for mike man
i love talking boxing you think it's
going to wake us just fighting the guy
your weight
no but you're right you're right you're
right you think you're afraid
to get your weight most feared guy in
the division yeah the beast you know the
division what the beast of the division
that's what it is no and they're not
not just on top of that but then you add
another world title to i mean that's
to me that's your hall of famer bro
no doubt about that
yeah i've done i've done more than i
even imagined
you know um if we if you go back
i mean i i fought i told you uh one of
the memorable fights that we're talking
about
against dejean that makes it memorable
too because i've i won the wbc
lightweight title title that my dad
wanted to kind of have at home you know
he didn't have the wbc with my brother
he didn't win the wbc
with with fernando so i was able to
bring that yeah that's like a footballer
and because he always said that i was
going to be a three-division champion
he always said that i would be champion
i fell away super featherweight and
lightweight
but now i've even done him better and
did you know a title at 140.
and now i'm in search of a fifth
division title at 147 you know so
you mentioned overachiever you know it's
it's that you know whenever someone says
this is your your max this is your limit
i want to
you know do more yeah for sure it's like
when you just said that
because my coaches here my coach uh who
brought me up in wrestling since i was
uh
since i first laced up wrestling she was
like he's here who would be a customer
for mike
yeah and uh he always says that a lot
was like man you've over exceeded my
[ __ ] expectations
dude and that feels good it was good to
come out of your
coach you know what i'm saying so yeah a
big shout out to richard females who's
here
big rich big rich so laying in the cut
yeah i mean that's that's what makes
that's what keeps me going that's what
motivates me more
to just keep achieving like i'm not done
uh i believe
i'm gonna be champion two more times you
know two come on baby
i ain't i'm done get that goal i'm
talking about you all the way to 100
you're talking about 54.
maybe not in divisions but oh okay
hey dude but you can you know what i'm
saying i mean if
you if you pick the right opponent maybe
but that's not really what i want to do
you know
i'll be championing at 47 and i'm gonna
come down come back down to 140.
you know i'll be championing again at
140. so like i said you know two or
three more times
i'll definitely be champion before i
retire you fight the english guy well if
he wins
yeah yeah he got a tough fight with you
yeah that's a fight he's a tough fight
with with jose ramirez but if
you know if the belts are available or
if the fight is available present to me
i'll definitely jump in there that would
be awesome thank you
you always conduct yourself like a
gentleman you know with humble and stuff
i respect you guys
thank you yeah well mikey it's been an
honor man for me like i've been
meaning to i feel like i already know
you you know what i'm saying without
even getting to know because you know
it's our first meeting here man i just
want to wish you luck man it's been a
blast
mike any last words here for mike it's
been a
an honor to be here thanks thanks for
having me on the show i mean pleasure
it was great great to to be here and uh
you know i hope i i continue to give
you know those memorable fights you know
so that we can add more titles and more
absolutely let's defend yourself he's
always defend you know defense yep
so you guys just watch hotbox with mike
tyson i'm your co-host aka triple c
henry cejudo
and this is mike tyson and we're out
[Music]
you